foreign
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
uh I am Brian and today's guest is one
of my favorite fighters of all time not
just for the in-ring performances but
for the mic skills for the entertainment
for everything he bought to it surely
he's got to be in the Hall of Fame it's
chill Sonnen thanks for coming on me
Ryan what is happening man I've been
counting down the days I'm pumped to be
here with you
um
honestly this is a surreal moment I uh
remember getting the pizzas and beers in
we're all my boys watching you fight and
beat the living hell out of Anderson
Silva and little did I know that one day
I'd get to have a talk with you man it
is on such an honor and you know I
mentioned the Hall of Fame there uh
we've seen
um you know cowboy Cerrone get his uh
little moment the other day and it was a
lovely moment but how on Earth are you
not in the Hall of Fame surely yeah I
gotta tell you that and that is
something that I want like guys kind of
play koi with that oh whatever happens
and I don't really care I
when somebody picks that and your
career's done and somebody else
one of your peers a group of your look
back and they bestow that I think that
is awesome Cowboy went in and you know
the Cowboys story is very misleading
unless you followed it because he
changed weight classes so much like some
people will look at his record it's like
well you gotta understand those were in
different weight classes those were on
uh five days notice those were without
training camps some of those were Main
Events by around but he won a whole
bunch of fights like I just described
but yes it goes both ways I thought it
was pretty cool uh but he got recognized
you know he stopped doing movie work now
a cowboy I've seen three different
movies during uh covid that's got cowboy
in them yeah I love the fact that he
said yeah um I got on steroids I feel
great uh like he just he was so honest
about it and with everything you've done
for the sport and when I look back at
your career before this interview and
seeing you know the pay-per-view numbers
you and Anderson did and I think you're
one of the the the real single-handed
people who are instrumental in making
this from just a pure gritty horrible
sport in many people's eyes too
entertainment you brought the WWE there
and yet I remember seeing some of your
first press conferences you were quite
quiet and you weren't that guy so
everyone talks about their Colby
Covington switched that flip and I know
you were released by the UFC Once Upon a
Time as well was there a moment where
you realized like I gotta turn this up
here yes I mean I remember where I was I
was driving an old pickup truck that I
had I was headed down 205 I was headed
to the B
with Ariel and as big as Daryl is now it
was a little different about that not
everything uh was face to face or in
that beautiful Studio he was still you
know picking up the phone and dictating
some stuff but I was getting ready to
take on you Shino Kami and I was ranked
number nine in the world and Okami was
ranked number two Okami was the last guy
to beat Anderson Silva it was by
disqualification but he had a win over
Anderson and um we're getting ready to
fight out in the Forum in LA and we are
not on the main card we were the only
match that had two top ten guys against
each other that was not on the main card
and yeah I blamed it all on you you
know he was being too nice and he was
being so polite and this was about honor
and respect and and bow and I I just cut
a heel promo on it but I I meant it all
it was very authentic I mean I got to go
and fight on under cards in front of
these guys the number two guy in the
world the hardest fight that I've ever
had and nobody's gonna see it what is
the point of doing all of this and it's
all because of him nobody wants to tune
in nobody wants to see him been on the
main card I draw this guy and now I'm
I'm pulled off and you sure went on to
be one of my my very good friends but it
was just one of these heel uh promos and
Brian I had a hard time doing that by
the way I appreciate you you recognizing
that I I was kind of responsible for the
entertainment era because it's something
it was a contribution that I made but
um I had a really hard time I had one
commissioner who wasn't gonna license me
and he even said that I was a bad
example for kids I had never used
profanity I I still did this day Sports
Illustrated named me the greatest
talker in sport but I've never actually
said the word spelling it for you right
now is in school you know I was very in
a box and um I just thought that was
inappropriate and this guy was falling
40 and he wasn't going to license me
because what a bad sport I was I didn't
have honor and respect and and I was
nothing for kids to look up to and he
didn't license me by the way he got his
weight I was in Nevada they were gonna
let me do the ultimate fighter opposite
Michael Bisping I did not get my license
and I did not do The Ultimate Fighter he
made me sit in timeout all because of
interviews that I had done when I was in
college wrestling I could just tell you
one more when I was in college wrestling
this is before the internet was a thing
but we had our local paper down in
Eugene I was doing interviews like this
I was calling other teams and I was
talking this up and I was trying to Hype
a match they killed the spot and the
coach told the interviewer no more
interviews with jail they cut me off for
media so they just didn't understand it
and I was trying to go go guys just run
it just one or two of these things it's
gonna work this is gonna be helpful but
they didn't see it it's okay to get in a
cage mono and mana and beat the living
hella of each other but it's not okay to
say some bad words
um and the fact that you didn't actually
sway which is something that's you're so
good at putting someone down like you
must have a hell of a vocabulary because
that is often missed on people why was
the reason you didn't swear because it
is it's very helpful sometimes if you're
wanting to say something for sure well
and so and so I wanted to be the bad guy
but I wanted that to be be a little bit
confusing like I wanted people to like
me while I was being uh the heel and
that's a really hard thing to do like I
mean uh I don't mean to compare myself
to the Rock but that would be an example
of a cool heel it's extremely hard to do
so I just thought okay I'm gonna go up
to these guys I'm gonna break all of
these rules I'm gonna tear down all
these barriers that we got but I'm not
gonna swear and as long as I don't do
that there'll still be guys that are are
worse than me
a bad guy a persona but I I didn't want
to actually have character problems or
being perceived like that so it wasn't
an overly uh thought out but but that
was uh the reasoning at the time for me
when I'm watching the UFC uh in this era
and I don't know why this is happening
but it feels like it is regressing a
little bit and more into a sport and
less entertainment obviously McGregor
hasn't fought anywhere near as much he
was another person who brought that sort
of Razzmatazz to it and it feels like
we're actually looking at less Stars
than I've seen in a long time in the UFC
although that might just be me but I'm
interested to get your take on it of do
you think there's a reason for that and
do you find yourself being frustrated
watching these modern day Stars not grab
the spotlight the way you did oh it
drives it drives me crazy and I love the
observation that you just made I mean
2022 from a business standpoint we've
never had a year like that I mean 2022
Dana White would be kicked out of the
office by 2007 Dana White I mean it was
a very different approach and I do see
what you're saying and we weren't really
building the stars and we weren't
getting behind him and promoting the
fights in the same way and then you go
and look at the gates and we're doing
you know 4.1 million for what was
supposed to be uh prohaska versus uh uh
uh Glover part two they ended up
changing that in the last second Uncle
Liam gets thrown they still did a 4.1
million I mean some of these gates are
just remarkable they're selling on
absolutely everywhere they go something
about the UFC though sorry to interrupt
you they can now get a little lazy and I
don't know if lazy is the right word but
they can rely on the brand more than the
personalities but I feel like with the
brand being bigger than ever it would
only supercharge it if some of these
guys like if we look at what party Pima
it was able to do with very little
um it wasn't like party was like the
most amazing performer in the Octagon
that we've seen but just the the the
personality that he had he immediately
became the most talked about thing in
the UFC because there's no one else to
compete with right now for me in terms
of him talking I I
feel like
I watch you do do it it's gonna get
missed you know Connor Connor really is
going to come in there and command it
and I see it the way you see it I think
that those are opportunities I think
that when you have that microphone you
you've got to really use it I think
everything's a competition if you're in
a press conference and you get asked two
questions and somebody else get it asked
12 questions I've been in that spot
before and I've grabbed my phone and I
text people that are in the audience
please ask me you're asking me this ask
me this is I mean all of that stuff is
is things that people pay attention to
it's what gets broken off it's what the
you and I's come and talk about it's
what really helps to Parlay and move it
and and I do agree with you it wasn't as
star driven in this last year the brand
was getting over not the athletes not
the matches it looks like that right now
as well I'm not really seeing a change
and I'd like one I like the
entertainment yeah I think when Dana
White is sat there getting frustrated by
all of these questions about Jake Paul
that really should be a wake up call him
of why you're then asking me questions
about my Fighters you know and I think
that's because Jake Paul has a similar
idea that you had you know let me just
talk the talk and try and walk the walk
as best as I can to pack it up was there
ever a point when you were when you were
going off on one of these speeches and
selling what you were gonna do to
another fighter where you sort of put
the mic down and walk backstage and then
thought Jesus Christ I've actually got
to go and try and do this to this create
this creature right now you know yes yes
some of
them so I'm upset they didn't really
understand it one of the first guys that
I ever broke this out on was a guy named
Paulo filo and I was uh relatively
undiscovered like I name dropped for you
a while ago that I got to a number nine
ranking I was ranked nothing at the time
of this I wasn't even the organization
they brought me in to go get beat up by
Paula who was 16-0 undefeated but he was
ranked number one Anderson was ranked
number two Paul was ranked number one
and they were workout partners and the
words coming out of the camp is that
that ranking was right Paula was the
best guy so it was I was I was building
that fight and get ready to fight him I
had just gotten signed I had no you know
no backstory other than I was a pretty
good Regional fighter so I came at it
pretty hard in my my big line was that I
I have a picture of him that I put in my
shoe so that every time I take a step
I'm walking right on his face that was
it but but at that time that was like
the worst that was the dirtiest thing
that had ever been said and I saw Paulo
filo's eyes after they played that form
and he looked sad it looked like that
hurt his feelings I felt terrible I
thought it was gonna work him up and
he's gonna he's gonna rip his shirt off
but we're gonna get this back and forth
he looked like I really hurt his
feelings I didn't say another bad thing
about the guy it bothered me that that
happened you eventually beat that guy
who was the wec champion unfortunately
he missed where and uh you didn't get
the belt that you deserved but you were
Will Champion but you you weren't Crown
Champion what was that experience like
that's so strange yeah and thanks for
saying that I mean that that was a hard
one that was a hard one for me I know
people said well I got you it's got to
be this Championship or not for me it
doesn't I don't care what words you put
in I don't care if you put intram in
front of whatever words you want to do
if it says world champion I've achieved
a life goal yeah so you know it was a
big deal and it was a rematch uh you
know it's hard to get to him the first
time building your way back getting to
him a second time and um they had never
had this happen this was in uh this was
in Florida and Mark Ratner himself told
me who was in charge of the rules he
said jail we never envisioned that a
champion would miss wait we've had
Challengers do it but we don't have any
mechanism within the rules we we didn't
know and he said moving forward if the
title holder is the one that misses wait
the title is still on the line and
that's what the sports done that's what
they've done uh ever since but for that
night it defaults down rules are the
same match is the same but it defaults
down to a non-title match he mailed me
that belt so I had the I have the
physical belt which I thought was a very
nice gesture but yeah to your point I I
wasn't Champion I don't I don't get the
claim that I was which hurt man that was
a real opportunity I wouldn't like to
have that money you've got it you've got
to give yourself that you've got a
you've got the belt you beat the
champion I mean what mode does anyone
have to do you know it's not your fault
no I
they'd go back
off topic what is going on what is the
vibe around you as it pertains to
Jeremiah versus Joshua is that a fight
that people are really wanting to see is
this Mega business oh good I mean that's
a good question mate uh you know what
the reality is this is the quietest
fight week that Anthony Joshua might
have had in in as long as I can remember
the so he has gone from selling out the
biggest stadiums in the UK to now he's
slowly selling tickets for a small uh
Arena now that
um just to give you some perspective on
it KSI the YouTube fighter sold out this
Arena twice much faster than what
Anthony Joshua is currently selling
tickets at now obviously those tickets
aren't cheap and but the fact is is the
reputation of Anthony Joshua as much as
I think he was a great champion and took
on all comers it has been damaged when
you look at his last five fights he has
lost uh three and out of the two he won
one was a decision against Andy Ruiz
where he popped the job and a lot of
people felt like he ran away he didn't
go out and bury this guy as he was
supposed to and then the other one
he was supposed to knock him out so
there's been a complete lack of these
devastating Mike Tyson type Knockouts
that he was basically known for on the
come up and it's it's do or die now for
Anthony Joshua's like and like Legacy in
terms of if he wants those huge fights
he needs to go out and put a beating on
this guy and it's a pretty hard fight to
to be expected to do that so he's in
he's caught between a rock and a hard
place right now I'm sensing that I mean
I'm feeling that over here I wasn't
overly familiar with Jeremiah I was an
overly familiar with ruiz I mean there's
ways to build matches but it just seemed
like you know you got Wilder you're
hearing even the the rumors of Francis
and Gano I thought maybe something
interesting was going to happen and uh I
was a little surprised at the match-up
frankly and I do you think it will sell
out do you think this will end up being
a big deal and by the way is Joshua
gonna win this fight I think he wins and
I think it will uh sell the the
remaining tickets but the problem was
Anthony Joshua is he is so he's such a
like nice guy and a Gentleman and he
never talks trash and when he tries to
he's terrible at it so like your selling
point is Knockouts and if you're not
giving those Knockouts to your fans and
you've only knocked that one guy in the
last five fights and you know music
really embarrassed him a little bit you
know like he put on an absolute
Masterpiece against him so he needs to
go in there and do what people and
remind people what he was great at and
uh but also um it's pretty much he'll
retire if he loses that's what he said
so it's pretty definitive it feels like
that and by the way there was a rumor
that I think his name is Chambers he
took on Mayweather and X Edition out of
the UK like a month ago there's a rumor
that that flop that nobody showed up for
that and it bombed is that accurate yeah
my friend went to that fight and he said
there was 2 000 tickets sold in a 20 000
Arena and 1 000 of those were probably
giveaways so sure and you know in the in
the other thousand were probably uh The
Money Team
um so it was humiliating for uh Floyd to
get to be going out there against a a
live opponent like don't get me wrong
Chalmers is a a reality TV star but the
guy has like Combat Sports Experience
like he thought MMA and Bellator I think
he did Muay Thai for years and he has
very fast hands so you're putting
yourself in a situation where all right
Floyd isn't going to get hit but is that
worth it like you know and I think that
there was probably a behind the scenes
investor who was convinced he was going
to make money on this and the thing with
Floyd is is how how much longer does
this carry on for and it seems like he
really intends to keep doing it and I
feel like he he might just pick the
wrong guy at some point I mean he's
heading towards 50 years old and he's
fighting young studs like Logan Paul who
they're not boxing at his level but it
just takes one shot one you know Zig
where you should have zagged and I just
don't see why he's doing it but I think
the money must be necessary for his
lifestyle yeah no I think that's right I
have more embellished Floyd Mayweather
's worth and I'm fine with that I never
thought the exhibition thing would work
if he's got somebody that wants to lose
some money I mean boxing has survived
over time because you got somebody
that's willing to lose some money to
attach himself to the tough guy business
so but I did hear that I heard the same
thing that you just said that there was
two thousand there was 20 000 seats
available somebody took a bath and that
might end the experiment at least at
least momentarily yeah it's it's a weird
thing to because when when Floyd did the
Logan Paul exhibition I was like okay
this makes sense this is a real big
moment people are interested we care but
now you know he seems to fight anyone
he'll he'll just get in there with any
YouTube kid and you know the specialness
has totally worn off now
um so yeah it is a bit embarrassing but
um I've got a question about your
experience with some of these great
Fighters because you know they call
Floyd the goat and they're all like the
only guy who has shared the octagon with
Fayette or Anderson Silva Jon Jones and
you spawned JSP so you might be the only
person who's ever you know legitimately
experienced what it's like to fight all
of these gold contenders who is your
goal I will tell you all of those guys
are awesome by the way just to get sour
grapes out inside those guys were great
but I George George St Pierre had a very
unique feel it's very hard for me to
explain uh the strength that he had I'm
blown away I was much bigger than him
I'm very surprised that his opponents
have not done interviews and talked
about uh The Uncanny strength he will
hold you in positions where you just
can't move and I've never been in that
spot particularly with somebody that's
smaller than me I mean when I went into
the workout I had a full head of
confidence that if I get in a jam I can
just use my size when you're trying to
be a good workout partner I want him to
invite me back and and make this
something I can do multiple times you
got to not use that size you got to not
use that power but I knew I could turn
to it if I had to and it I tell you what
it wasn't there I mean it was one of
these things where we're bumping him and
moving him uh using strength using size
it was just a few feel uh that was very
unique and then he had philosophies like
the great martial arts like Saint Bruce
Lee that sticks around for the ages
George had philosophies and one of his
philosophies is that you only go five
rounds in a workout you get you get
warmed up and you go five five minute
rounds and there's no point in being
conditioned to do anything different
that's what championship and that's just
what his belief was and it didn't matter
if he stayed up late the night before
what coach had in mind he was going to
get warm he's gonna go uh five fives he
was also extremely disciplined to detail
when we drilled together he would not
stop and release so okay now it's my
turn until everything was perfect and
he'd even go to leg locks and he'd
adjust and he'd turn his heel and he'd
turn his toe and he would look at it and
he'd drop his elbow down it was one of
these things where generally when I
drilled my whole life it was how fast
can you go it was a conditioning workout
it was this really hard Pace I go boom
he goes and George's wasn't like that it
was very technical these were just a
couple of things that that I remembered
but it did make him uh stand out and I I
thought you know overall for
well-roundedness I I think when they
talk about the goat they got to talk
about Saint Pierre the interesting thing
is that you've been very uh honest about
like one of the few actually and I'll
give you credit for this about yo ped
usage when I looked at George Saint
Pierre who was in what we kind of
referred to as the PED era before you
saw it uh when you look at George's uh
stomach that you know he had this tote a
shell like stomach and a lot of his
freaky strengths where he would
manhandle any anyone and he was in
better shape than every other fighter in
the non-usada era I wondered if you ever
questioned his
um you know lack of all usage of PEDs
yeah I always wondered that too I I mean
right there was something there where
it's such a slippery slope because usada
and wada are are so sensitive that if a
guy was in violation of that people
automatically think that it's uh
he retired just as you saw it I came in
and a lot there's a lot of people
speculating like you've been calling for
drug testing for years and the minute
they come in you're like right bye yes
no no I remember that time yeah it lined
up and so it was a little bit uh a
little bit interesting but gosh it's
hard to say I mean if you see George now
he looks the exact same I mean guys that
use pens or at least anabolics which
that's all that you and I are really
talking about is antibodies like
whatever the PED list is fire using
anabolics or not but guys that do that
their body changes when their career
changes George weighs the same thing you
know he's still in the practice room he
looks the same you go Pat him on the
back he's just as thick as he always was
I mean every now and then there are just
freaks of nature yoel Romero is one uh
first time I ever saw you well he was 19
years old representing uh the Cuban
national team he looked the exact same
competing at 100 185 pounds he was in
the Olympics in the year 2004 in the
finals at 185 pounds the same thing he
weighs today some guys just get lucky
bro obviously you had a lot of those
Fierce rivalries that you brought out of
people was there anyone who you
genuinely were like I hate this guy like
this is the most I've ever disliked an
opponent yes definitely uh vandelay
which I don't feel that way now now now
I like vandelay and and wish him well
but um yeah I vandalate well because he
frightened me he was one of these guys
why didn't nobody could trust him I I
knew when the fight started this guy was
vicious I mean they call him the ax
murder for good reason and he used to be
over in Prime they were kick guys when
they're down and stomp him in the face I
mean he really was a very vicious style
but I didn't know if I could trust him
before the referee said go I don't know
if I could trust him on stage I know if
I could trust him at press conferences
and I did an ultimate fighter with him
and we got into it two different times
one time they showed on TV but there was
also another time and so you just kind
of on edge and all times and I the only
thing I know about fight is the same as
any other guy which is whatever your
father told you and my father's thing
was not you can defend yourself if you
know if as long as he throws the first
punch my father's thing was don't ever
let them within range if they're upset
and they're within an arm's distance the
fight has now started so go and that was
the theme of Vandal is I could never let
him get close like as soon as he would
get in I couldn't trust him and so that
wasn't fun quite frankly that was kind
of an uneasy way to go about a life for
a while till we got that all resolved
that was a great moment for the TV
though when you said I can't let you get
close if you get close I'm gonna like
hit you like that was such a great
lesson for young men watching that like
this is my father's rule yeah that's
right like you can yell at me but you
can't do it with in this ring you just
can't yeah was there ever an element of
fear that you felt more so with any
opponent oh I would imagine I mean I
will tell you
thinking to myself like okay my whole
life I've heard the expression a lamb
going to slaughter this this is what
they're talking about I remember
thinking that like I was bouncing around
I had on this cool Road Tap Out gave me
a robe and I was walking on a robe and
everything was going well and I had the
face on but I remember thinking that oh
this is what that expression is about
wow and I hadn't been to 205 and I did
real well at 185 I hadn't been to 205
and then it was John you know which was
just something special there's something
long there there's something awkward
he's got these elbows
um some good wrestling to go I mean it's
just one of these things where if you go
and watch you know five Jon Jones fights
as a way of preparing for all you see is
this guy destroying five people it was a
very impressive highlight reel and I
thought I could beat him I thought I
could compete with him I thought I could
get him tired I mean I I was game for
the match but uh yes it was an it was an
awkward feeling to know at least what
was supposed to happen or what people
thought was going to happen your
relationship with Jon Jones is one of my
favorite my favorite sort of fight
arrival is because even though the fight
wasn't as competitive as what you would
have liked it to have been you really
got under this man's skin even to this
day and in the fact that he refused to
fight you on short notice and had like
almost a historic moment where UFC card
was canceled and you got a lot of man
points from the audience because you you
were like uh Shogun refused and Shogun
was one of the baddest people ever
Machida said no you said yes you turned
up and John's backed down to you so on
some level it's one one mate you know he
didn't show up you did I did get a lot
of credit for that I did get a lot of
Street uh cred for that and that was
part of my code I mean like everybody
has a code where I told you I didn't use
profanity but that was another one which
is I'm gonna say what I'm gonna say but
no matter what I will show up I will
show up anytime with anyone at any
weight under any rule set that was a
real cool thing when I was doing it now
as I'm looking back you know maybe that
was a reckless standpoint but I was
proud of that I was very proud of anyone
anytime anywhere I knew a lot of guys
said it but very few guys did it and
that includes John John said it too
until he he got called on and he said no
I was in Southpaw but it was interesting
like when I looked at John versus myself
I want to say he was like 23 and I was
36. I remember thinking he was clearly
more advanced than I was and but when he
backed down and said his boxing scares
me he's a southpaw I think he had more
like whatever his thought pattern was it
did put a little pep in my step where I
went man that's a real compliment I'm
being complimented here you know even if
it's by my enemy but there's something
here that's very sweet and looking at it
not the Jon Jones situation now it's
very interesting because the incident
with his wife the children asking the
hotel staff to call the cops and all of
that I found it very interesting that
the UFC even took him back because I
know he's a huge stall but this man is a
wild card at least and have you seen the
tweets from him in the recent days about
nonsensical tweets like that a lot of
people are thinking what's going on here
it's like another Jon Jones moment where
he's clearly not doing the life that he
should be doing yeah oh no I could tell
and sometimes he even blames it on red
wine or he's into deleting it Conor uh
disappointedly is it is into the
deleting the Tweet right I think if you
say you got to let it live and you can
bury it you could put out more there's
there's ways to handle that but just
deleting it the next day and not
addressing I don't know I'm not a big
fan of that I'll tell you this and it's
just for conversation but there was
there was a very tough moment Jon Jones
was with the police on the body Cam and
he declared that he had CTE he declared
that and it's a very big deal because
here in the states we are overseen by
the commission that works at the
discretion of the Attorney General who
was supervised by the governor that's
the exact same thing as the the police
so when the police you have an agency
that John is disclosing I have brain
damage too and he did it twice and I
only share that with you because if
another state agency goes and licenses
him and something goes awry and John
comes out and Susan says I told you you
had knowledge I told the police and it's
right here they are busted it I mean
you're talking about a 20 million dollar
lawsuit this would have been devastated
and the commission didn't even hold a
hearing the commission didn't even make
John check a box or sign off they acted
as though they hadn't seen him
proclaiming to his state agency that I
had brain damage it was a really big
deal it would have been a blunder I
understand that's a road we shouldn't
have gone down but that's the biggest
part of that whole story is that he told
an agency that he had bring it in
another state agency acted like they
didn't hear it and when you say that
footage of him smashing his own head off
of a police car I mean that's a it's not
normal behavior you know even for USC
Fighters well this was right after they
put him in the Hall of Fame
thing was going his way and
I don't know what all what all what all
he's into I mean he's pretty open
the party and go and have a good time
but but somewhere in there because I
will tell you in all fairness as hard as
I am on John I will share with you if
you catch him in the middle of day and
he's sober he he's uh he's very humorous
he's very charismatic he can smile he
can he can dance and and kind of get a
rise out of the crowd he's a narcissist
but it can be endearing uh believe it or
not but then you know over the course of
the evening he seems to to be a
liability he seems to be a guy that you
might not want to be around do you
believe his denials of paid usage or not
no I don't know why he would deny him I
mean earlier like when I locked up with
him and I had a high
ER trade than Tropicana when I locked up
with him in our fight he pushed me
straight backwards in that octagon I
mean I mean this was like a Mack truck
versus a Volvo and I remember as he was
pushing me backwards which no I fought
50 men including heavyweights nobody's
done that too as I'm backing up I
thought to myself I know your secret
because I have the same one I know what
you're doing cause I'm doing it too and
you apparently are doing a little bit
more it was just one of those things you
know his body looked a certain way this
was a guy his biggest enemies in terms
of somebody to come out and talk trash
about John was his own teammates and
that just came from a jealousy
standpoint they would go to the gym
every day twice a day they'd be on time
he would do none of those things he'd
come in a few times a week he he would
show up late he would leave early and
then he'd go beat everybody up make
millions of dollars and uh you know get
gifted a Bentley it was just one of
those things where it was his own
teammates that that would bury him but
you would see his body my God I I mean
he was in three times more more sculpted
than I was and I never missed practice
I've never tasted alcohol I it's it's
one of those things where
um you know you can't do that you just
can't snap your fingers and change your
body like that unless you're getting
help and I like performance ants in
myself I know people try to give it a
hard time but performance enhance it
those are positive terms I know people
try to make it a negative and it might
be against the rules that maybe athletes
violated things which is called cheetah
but I'm just performance and these
are positive things I mean it's one of
my problems with the rocker even with
with the hulkster I wish they would tell
people or with John Cena said come out
and tell people you guys aren't breaking
the rules you guys have discovered
something that's making you better share
that with the world don't hide it from
them and in terms of Jon Jones uh at
heavyweight is there a person who you
feel is the biggest threat to him you
know what X's and O's is Curtis blades
Curtis blades John's highest achievement
in amateur wrestling was a junior
college national championship Curtis won
that exact same championship and Curtis
is just a big guy he's a little bit
younger Curtis does lead the right
lifestyle he doesn't like to come out
and do a lot of interviews but Curtis is
a solid guy I mean he gets up in the
morning he's very disciplined he's got
coaches he works hard he can go five
rounds if he needs to I don't know that
I would Proclaim that anybody could go
with John that really is a once in a a
lifetime uh athlete
um you know the fact that he just took
three years off changed weight classes
and and and had surreal gone so
frightened he didn't have to fight him I
mean he had him so frightened
psychologically he didn't even have to
go fisticus man that's an impressive
thing it it truly is I think the Francis
fight would have been fun I think John
probably would have thrown him down
ultimately and I think Steve is a hard
match I mean I really do steep is uh 40
years old but one thing about Stipe and
people don't know this yet is Steve from
his last fight which was against Francis
he waited at 230 33 pounds he put on 20
pounds of muscle Stipe thought he was
going into a Trilogy with Francis
zangano so he changed his whole
lifestyle much like what Jon Jones just
did just to put on size and it 20 pounds
of muscle on Stipe is a very different
steep Bay I'm I'm open to the idea yeah
I like obviously Steven is a legend I
like him but I I find his uh infrequent
fighting frustrating I think John was
very right in saying you better take
some time off of the fire uh Brigade boy
if you want to come and fight me but for
me uh Tom hospital I know I might be a
bit biased with him being British but
the guy is lightning fast and has a
really good ground game uh really good
stand up but you mentioned before about
this um CTE obviously you've had a lot
of fights do you ever worry about your
brain health given how like how sharp
you are and how how much you are all
about like you know talking for a living
yeah or does that ever cross your mind
yes uh and it didn't it used to I used
to think in you know it was something
that somebody saw somebody I looked up
to could have even been my father said
oh you know that's a guy looking for an
excuse having a concussion and things
like this then that movie came out
called concussion with Will Smith and he
was based on a true story and it
impacted me at least made me start
thinking in that direction that I did
see several Fighters a lot of boxers
that were slowing down and having a hard
time even the great Muhammad Ali just by
example so you start to see me and this
is a real thing then the guys in the NFL
and some of them were even leading to
suicide and they were talking about you
know the the pains and the depression
they're having from CT so yes I mean I'm
I'm very aware of it I I don't believe
that I uh that I took some of those
shots but um I think it's a very real
thing I I appreciate that coaches are
monitoring it that doctors now know what
to look for I mean that one for the
longest time we didn't even know what to
look for I was in uh college wrestling
rooms and a few uh headbutted and you
were seeing stars as they say you just
get back in there Shake It Off and um
it's a little bit more serious than that
I'm glad that we have the protocols in
place that are are starting to be formed
I've heard Mike Bisping and a few other
people describe what it's like to wake
up after was there was there any time
that you remember where you lost a
specific period of time where when you
finally came to it was uh you know you
remember that I felt as though I got hit
by a missile 5 seconds into my fight
with Fedor I mean this thing was a
missile comes and it takes me and I
would have quit that fight right as I
was falling to the canvas I knew if this
fight gets stopped it'll be the fastest
knockout ever and I start I'm a windmill
in my leg I just am trying to get a
couple of seconds you know so it's not
not the not the record setting but I
felt as though after that fight I felt
as though for a couple of months that uh
that something was amiss my memory
wasn't quite there or maybe I'd be
speaking and and I was having a hard
time finding the word I've actually
wondered because I've never known is
this real or is this in my mind have I
have I created that this is happening as
an excuse from the punch I really don't
know but that is the one if I could take
any shot back I've ever taken and be
that missile fade or gave me yeah I mean
there's a reason he's in the gold
conversation the man hits bloody hard
and going uh to one of the other go to
before Anderson Silva
um I always wondered
um after you beat the living hello with
him for all those rounds and and
obviously didn't come away with the win
you get back into say the locker room
what what are you feeling like in that
moment because you did so well this was
at a point where we'd never seen even a
a little bit of Anderson Silva and not
looking like a dominant fighter you
called it all beforehand we didn't
really believe you for being like you
know and then you went and did it and
beat the living hell out of them what
was the emotions like after that it was
devastating oh my goodness it was so
devastating I mean my whole life you
know I want to be world champion a poor
me that I didn't get but this was his
closest
I'm gonna get right I had the the
NCAA the weight scale issue and then you
know found a way to let this one go I
had never been uh that exhausted as a
human being before I tried to get there
in practice I tried my whole life to get
there at practice but but I had never
gotten to that point and I didn't know
what round it was my my corner before
the fifth round told me it was the
fourth round and I believed them and I
think that's a really weird excuse for a
guy to go I didn't know what Roundup but
but I didn't know I mean I was that
level of exhausted I was also very
fearful of Anderson I I had a real
urgency to get him down I I respected to
the point of fear his stand-up so that
but that urgency made me sharp that
night it made me it made me quicker it
made my pressure better it made my
timing and my range there's one thing
that I lost for the rematch the first
fight went so well and in the rematch I
didn't have that same uh fear and
urgency but
um yeah it was just a devastating thing
and I was kind of getting it explained
to me right when I got out of the ring
one of the first people I saw was Joe
Silva and he he came around and he shook
my hand and I said sorry because Joe's
big thing was just inner entertainment
were you excited and I just said sorry I
couldn't you know I just couldn't get
going tonight and I went back and they
this guy brought me the the of the night
bonus check he says hey Lorenzo and Dana
want you to have this and and I took it
and I opened it and saw it was the fight
of the night and I thought okay those
guys feel bad for me they're giving that
to me because they feel bad for me I was
not aware I was just not aware that it
was a good fight or that people liked it
um they ended up having a stat that I it
was 311 punches for me to eight punches
by him but I didn't know that I felt
like you know we were out there Tit for
Tat and we were trading I I just it got
to a level of exhaustion where I was
very unaware and when people ended up
liking the fight it was at least
nominated for fight of the year it might
have even won it I had no idea it was a
good fight I really when I told Joe
sorry I meant it yeah it's it's a weird
sort of uh thing to have on your record
do maybe have the most dominant defeat
in the history of UFC title fights I
mean like you was so dominant for so
long as well it wasn't like it was a you
know it was such a long amount of time
where we watched you swing in the Hammer
as you called it and um you know what I
wish you'd have won that mate I really
do because you deserved that that you
literally took everything uh but that's
why he was such a great fighter to be
fair to the guy I appreciate that very
much and yeah I agree Anderson Silva's a
great competitor right he was always
known for his skills and for his
techniques and for his setups but that's
a competitor man you gotta have a heart
you you've got to want it and have that
burning desire to be able to hang in
there let alone come back let alone find
a way and yes he he I don't know he got
enough credit like when that fight was
done a lot of the talk was uh you know
the rounds that I had won but there's
another side to it which is he hung in
there and he found a way with a minute
left to to keep his belt and keep his
legacy and I I really respected him one
of the things I've heard you speak about
a little bit before was was the um
obviously you talk about your dad quite
a lot in conversation and how much he
meant to you and I think it's it's
lovely that you still keep him alive in
the way you do
um and obviously you had that moment
where you made that promise to him
um for those that don't know about
becoming a world champion do you think
that you maybe put too much pressure on
yourself through through what it what it
what you built it up into from loving
your dad so much and all of that
possibly possibly um and possibly stayed
in there a little bit longer uh you know
as well you know looking back staying in
there until you're 42 years old I think
that I think that's probably on uh a
little bit further you know the
Fighter's kind of the last one to know
when the sun has set the whole world
sees it at least a year before the
athlete does and I was I was definitely
guilty of that I was selling myself on
some of the ideas if I'm training uh I'm
training smarter not harder like as my
body was wearing down and I I couldn't I
couldn't put the work in that uh coach
Clinton hires needed I sold myself but
yeah but I'm but this is smarter I'm
doing better I'm actually going to get
further everybody has to do that at some
point right I mean most of our careers
do in the same which is face down and
embarrassed uh Lennox Lewis or Saint
Pierre I guess you'd have to put khabib
in there
um very rare very rare Mayweather style
career so yeah on some hands I think
there was some some pressure that that
was maybe maybe undue maybe I I
misunderstood that uh you know now that
I am a father I want my young man to do
that you know through his years of
education uh whatever his sport is
whatever it is he wants to do but I
would keep him active keep him busy send
him home tired I don't want him out you
know roaming around with his friends
nothing good happens with a young man in
free time so I would like to just take
take my son's time away uh teach him a
skill and have him go home tired I think
that's really what my dad was after but
uh we parted ways before he explained
that to me for some reason you didn't
actually do the retirement in the cage
was there a reason for that because I I
would have thought that the chailed son
in retirement speech would have been the
one to end all speeches well I
appreciate that you know I I didn't know
and quite frankly even when you retire
it's you make it look as though okay
this is my idea and this is my decision
but there's always more that goes into
it at that time I was with Bellator did
Scott Coker want me back if he did want
me back did he want me in the same
position or was I going to start sliding
down the card which is which is kind of
the hint you know here's your hat what's
your hurry and so you have you have a
few of those things you got to go you
got to collect your thoughts talk to
your family see who's available see what
it looks like the next match is likely
to be and uh you know if you don't have
more more checks in the positive column
sometimes you come in and act like this
was the time and I was gonna do it all
along but like everything it's just part
of the ACT if you for for whatever
reason you were feeling amazing and you
could come back and fight one you know
fighter would there be a guy who would
be tempt you out Tito Ortiz
Peter Ortiz you don't want to be
keto and
Andy had and I I mean it really was he
he it was brutal things that people
never saw things where I came up to
Amanda man I'd known him for 20 years I
competed with him in college
and we had our moment and he just
smeared my face in it and I just
remember going what a jerk and I'm
standing there I stood there and took it
but but inside I thought Tito do you
know what this is like in my shoes you
won I lost I gotta go to the same press
conference because it's procedure I'm
gonna I'm gonna go and I'm gonna put you
over all I want to do is get in my hotel
room and scream you know he's given me
the business in in the back and I I just
it was one of those things that if I if
I could get a match with Tito I would
take it yeah it was a strange one to
watch that I I felt he got
Tito had this little thing about him
where he could get lucky uh uh like I
remember him having this fight where
everyone was like he has finished he has
done was it Ryan Bader in the UFC where
he pulled out a submission out of
nowhere he was a bit more slick on the
map than people gave him credit for and
he he would win a couple of fights like
yourself and Ryan Bader where you were
like how did Tito do that but you know
he probably was better than what we we
give him credit for but yeah I I think
you were very unfortunate because I
fully expected you to steamroll him
there no I appreciate I can see that
position I could have let go I could
have spun behind him I mean just the x's
and o's right there in my head and yet
Tito was a good competitor you know he
was a rough guy he's a real physical guy
I don't know that he did other sports
growing up then we got into wrestling
real early and was kind of from a tough
neighborhood with street life he
respected his career enough to stick a
needle in his ass every now and then so
he was you know he was pretty strong you
get in certain positions before you
could wear him down and and they were
some some real threats but uh yeah that
was a tough one to lose to man Tito Tito
uh definitely enjoys winning and that
was his moment but you know the Winner's
got to be a little bit polite to the
loser at least a little bit yeah I don't
think Tito had the like I don't think he
could quite Let It Go the things that
you said that got under his skin you
must have really got under his skin to
be fantastic what I will say is when I
discovered the UFC
his era was Chuck and Randy was was what
was really blowing MMA up and it is a
bit weird now when I look back at the uh
you're saying I mean Chuck's still in
and around it but to see Tito and Randy
who was so instrumental in blowing the
UFC up basically removed from history
um what do you make of that yeah that's
tough that's tough and you know I'll
throw another one in there is uh Frank
Shamrock you know Frank Shamrock there
wasn't very many times when we truly
knew who the best in the world was we
knew the world champion was but to
actually know okay that guy he's proven
it he's gone through everybody I don't
have any suggestions that's the guy
we've only had that a few times I would
bring vandelay from uh his pride days I
would um definitely bring uh Chuck
Liddell and I would definitely bring
Randy in and for a period of time it was
Tito Tito knew how to get people down he
knew how to go five rounds he would put
you in the fence he understood the
elbows with positioning so he wasn't
caught in arm bars I mean I think those
guys should be remembered for what they
were and the same goes with with Frank
Shamrock and Frank did it just to remind
you when it was 205 pounds they did not
have a 185 they did not have a 170. they
just had 205 in heavyweight the most he
ever weighed in at was 193 and he had
his clothes on when he did that but he
weighed 193 that's his official uh
weight I remember because we were at a
Stanford wrestling shirt but I actually
talked to Frank I I saw him at fedor's
retirement fight we were in the cage
next to each other I've never really
visited with him and I said by the way
just wanted to tell you you did a really
great job and you you were a true
champion and you did it giving up all
that weight and he told me that he most
he's ever weighed in his life was
178. Frank Shamrock is is one of those
guys that we need to take a second look
at I want to talk to you about some of
these funny beefs that I see you having
on Twitter because the way you mock John
Cena for example is absolutely hilarious
is you you still love a few of this
Anthony Joshua 50 Cent John Cena is
there a reason why these these people
get on your nerves and you just want to
like take the piss out of them jealousy
it's it's pure jealousy I can't stand it
look at Anthony Joshua's World trip plus
he gets to be handsome please like six
three and he he gets to be handsome on
top of everything else he got to go to
the Olympic Games he gets to be a
national hero John Cena drives me crazy
because what John's another one of these
guys that denies anabolic use and I
don't know why he's not cheating he's
not breaking any rule he's not buying it
illegally he's getting from his
prescription from a doctor it's
something that could help people and I
so that just frustrates me and secondly
he's not even on Twitter he's like this
is clearly an assistant that that is
putting out these messages that are
taken from a book They're they're not is
he doesn't engage they're not back and
forth he's got like he's got like 15
times more followers than I do so yes it
is pure jealousy I love it and I rate
the honesty
um one one fighter you had a beef with
uh not long ago which I really enjoyed
the back and forth with with you and
Connor uh it kind of felt like it was
more Connor having a problem with you
pointing things out and you know him
having a sensitive ego I remember you
being on stage with Bisping and Connor
when Connor was just starting to sprout
and now he's coming at you what what was
that whole situation like I did not like
it I I did not I did not like that
Connor did that in public and we've got
our own private relationship and he
could have done he's never come at me
like that in public I looked at Conor
like like little brother I've had to
correct the story I've had to come in
and clean up many messes that he's done
but I thought he viewed me the same way
I thought he and went and so when he did
that I go oh oh I'm a Fool he doesn't uh
view me the way that I view him or that
I I thought he looked at me you know
then I felt a little bit foolish but I
let him know I mean I told him this this
is my last warning if we're gonna do
this we're gonna do but you can stop
right now stop right now we'll call the
whole thing off and he stopped he
stopped so I mean I I continued on the
path of uh you know trying to explain
Conor I feel like he's a little bit
misunderstood I thought it was a great
Entertainer you know the last Conor we
saw he's broken in half he's on the
canvas doing an interview with Joe Rogan
and he's talking about the opponent the
opponent's wife and so many people said
well you know how disrespectful would a
jerk and it's like yes quite possible or
you have an Entertainer that is so
committed he is going down with the ship
till the final note is played and you
know it's it's one of those two but I'm
not certain that we know you know I feel
like you really get your money's worth
with Conor I feel like he he entertains
and adds a value that nobody else does
in ways that nobody else does I agree I
was a huge Conor McGregor fan and I've
definitely gone off him as the years
have gone on just the thing is is like
it's the lack of consistency like it's a
little bit like Tyson Fury as well like
you have to tell a consistent story to
be believable for us to invest in what
you're saying and it flip-flops with him
and he says one thing and does another
and I'm very surprised that he is coming
back after breaking his leg in such a
bad way
um and to take on Michael Chandler you
know for all I I don't like him as much
as I used to the guy's got balls because
that is a rough fight to come back after
a leg break right thought when Michael
Chandler has been out here looking
fantastic even if he hasn't been winning
all the time he's he's top five probably
what do you make of that as a matchup
for the first fight back well I'll tell
you what some here isn't passing the
smell test I mean if I was just to back
up on the timeline so all of a sudden
Connor's back he's going to take on
Chandler great why why are these two
fighting moreover when are they fighting
where are they fighting at what weight
class are they fighting so we're told
these 255 owners are gonna fight at 170.
now that was weird because now it's not
for contendership we know it's not for
Championship but now it's not for
contendership or even for rankings so
why are we doing this just as a pure
cash grab okay but that's not generally
the way that it's done so then they come
out they correct the statement and they
said no 155 pounds is where the weight
class is so they go to Michael Chandler
and Chandler says 155 they then go to
Connor and Connor says no it's at 170.
so we don't even have a weight class
agreed upon I think that's weird
secondly Conor's boots on the ground and
he put out a tweet that he's going I
mean if I'm to take him literal and I do
that he's setting up camp at Big Bear
he's just starting to everybody's come
in he's rented out Big Bear well Camp is
something that Connor traditionally does
eight to ten weeks before a fight and
he's not in the usada pool usadas spoke
up and said from the day he enters he
must give us six months which is 180
days Connor's come out and disputed that
but I mean between the two the agencies
himself or the athlete we we have to
think that it's the agency and Conor
still hasn't enlisted in the pool he
hasn't started that clock and that's a
very precarious thing I I mean first off
are we getting ready to see a feud
between Connor and usada if so sign me
up but I want to know secondly the
athletic commission has the right to
come in and test him if they're in his
state they're in his State he is boots
on the ground in Nevada filming The
Ultimate Fighter they could walk right
up to him now and I only say that
because so many people are speculating
the reason he's put off getting in the
pool is he's still hot he did something
to to heal his knee that's still in his
system okay that would be a great reason
to not go in the pool I will just remind
you usad is not the end-all be-all you
still have the state commission and he's
boots on the ground and they're elected
to not go in fantastic that's fagazi
this whole thing is very odd and
supposedly he's gonna fight Chandler
where are they gonna fight at what
weight are they going to fight out who
else is on the card when are we doing it
when are they on sale where's the
announcement where's the poster
something about this is not right
interestingly when Dana White was
questioned on it he said I don't get
involved in all of that anymore and I'm
like it's the first time I've ever heard
you say that so if anyone is going to
get special treatment it probably is
Conor McGregor but yeah it does seem
very strange have you ever had a fight
where after turning pro where a guy
didn't know you were a fighter and he
found out the hard way
oh like like in the streets yes yes I
have um I'm not a puncher to to begin
with
um you know I my I'm always gonna grab
you it's always going to be but but yes
I I've had a couple of those where
nothing happened he didn't find out the
heart he but other people came around
like
and set him straight you know pull them
back or whatever the separation was and
then tell him and then he would come
over and apologize and you know say
things like oh man that would have been
really bad for me I didn't know and I
just had something like that happen I
was at the NCAA uh wrestling tournament
I had this weird thing like that but it
was the same situation I mean nobody
touched each other but people came
around they told him man step back you
you got this one wrong
yeah someone did him a favor that day
um and and you mentioned uh earlier
about uh your philosophy as a father you
come across as like Uncle Chael you know
it to a lot of people and even as your
subscribers we watch you and you drop a
lot of Life advice and I think that
that's great that you do that because
you know we're in a society right now
where there's a lot of fatherless Sons
out there you know and I just wondered
what what is your sort of broad
philosophy in terms of being a dad to
your kids in terms of discipline and and
how you're trying to guide them through
life well I'll tell you I'm still I got
my little maniac right over here
sleeping in a chair uh we'll go get some
ice cream after this but I'm still
learning I mean there isn't a manual on
that but I I do believe that there is
something very important in uh
supporting the kid in in terms of let's
try some different things whatever it
might be and it doesn't even have to be
athletic related but let's find some
things let's see what you like and then
I'm basically the chauffeur right I'll
I'll pay the dues whatever they are I
gotta write the check and then I gotta
get him there I gotta get him home but
we got to do it every day and I just
think there's a real importance uh
particularly with a young man I have a
daughter as well but a young man in free
time that that just never works out I
know a lot of really good people males
between the ages of 18 and 25 really
good people but between the ages of 18
and 25 they made one bad decision one
bad decision one given to peer pressure
one they were up too late and they they
just made a decision and it changed
their lives you know some of them are in
prison some of them hurt they're injured
death things like this so yeah I really
like the idea of sending the kids
somewhere uh where he uses a lot of
energy he learns the skill and he comes
home tired I think that that's important
but I think it's something you've got to
do it every single day my I will I will
always know where my kids are I'll tell
you that have you ever had a
conversation with your little boy about
fighting about you know if a kid starts
a fight in school how to handle that
that sort of thing yeah yes yes we
definitely have um he's at a younger age
you know Brian it's a different system
now you know they got this anti-bullying
I mean these kids are really nice to
each other they don't even use uh you
know bad words they don't call each
other jerks and nerds and I mean a
little simple stuff like this so we've
had those and he's had a couple of
formal boxing classes and the coaches
are real good at explaining uh you don't
do this you you have the confidence to
know you don't need to do this and you
don't do this you can really hurt
somebody so we've had those talk but
they weren't from like a Bravado of you
go out there and you take it to him it
was nothing like that it was it was it
was keep your eyes on them keep your
distance and find a way out of there one
thing that really surprised me obviously
you've always been the most stand-up guy
and we've seen a lot of USA Fighters had
legal issues but we've never seen you in
any situation where you know you've
looked in any other way other than a
gentleman and yet there was the footage
I came out of you obviously being
escorted out by police security hands
behind your back looked like it had a
ripped shirt and it was a very strange
thing as a fan of you I'm like this
can't be right there's some there's
something uh up here and um from what I
understand you're in a situation where
criminal charges have been dismissed is
that correct there are some that are
dismissed but there are some that are
still withstanding there was six or
there was eight people involved in this
which I gotta tell you I don't really
like the score of that I mean not for
nothing
they're drinking I'm not I got a shirt
ripped off my face is bloody and there's
six of you I don't really understand why
I'm the one why I'm the one being taken
away and my own lawyer said you're never
gonna have whether it's the the D.A the
police are a jury No One's Gonna feel
bad for a prize fighter who gets in a
fight with non-prized fights I said even
if there's six of them really they're
all fine I don't throw any punches
meanwhile I'm my face is bleeding yeah
you're the one you're the one that's
gonna have the problem here and you know
it was just it was one of those tough
spots I gotta tell you it is still
ongoing but I want to show respect to
your questions that you did ask it but
it was a very frustrating position
because they asked me have you taken
anything and I've never drank I've never
tasted alcohol took an Ambien I was in
my room I was going to sleep I thought
that was an honor I thought I would get
credit for that hey what an honest guy
there's no test for Ambien you either
admit that you or I said I took an
ambulance they tried to use that against
me oh he he didn't know where he was he
was on an ambulance no it's what are you
talking about I answered a question
honestly there's six of you I'm bleeding
you're fine and believing you wouldn't
be if I started throwing but it was just
a really weird thing and then they
started having fun Brian I gotta tell
you the people that were involved with
this started having fun they tried to
hold a press conference I mean they flew
in to hold a press conference they show
up in special outfits nobody shows up so
it gets canceled I got written by TMZ
that told me we have never been
contacted by somebody as often as we're
contacted by these people like they're
just having fun and it's a it's a it's a
highly
odd spot for me to be in I I don't feel
as though this is a hard one for me to
prove that I didn't beat you up you
aren't beat up and I'm really good at
beating people up well I mean but that
kind of solves the problem like you
don't really get to say Jail jail came
out and he teed off on me you're fine
yeah and that is not a likely result
like I wasn't as good at this as Fedor
and Jon Jones but I was pretty damn good
I can handle I can handle some people in
a hallway with no training it was just a
really weird thing everything you're
saying makes a lot of sense now chill
because obviously we know you're a
stand-up guy like if you are gonna have
issues as an MMA fighter it's going to
be consistent as we've seen with the Jon
Jones you know and it is a shame because
your career should not be used against
you you know it the fact that you happen
to be a fighter shouldn't automatically
make people think you're some Barbarian
like there are a lot of very small
intellectual Fighters you know so you
know think fingers crossed that this All
is resolved for you and you can go back
to being the bad guy because you are a
good guy ironically but I one last
question how would you like to be
remembered how would I like to be
remembered I was I was very proud of the
code I mean I had my own code and I
fiercely adhered to the code but
um it was anyone anywhere anytime anyway
class when I got into the sport I I had
my my fifth bite during for my fifth
fight is the first time I ever saw scale
they had never put us I had never had a
way and even a mock way in where
everybody's going heavy whipping we
never even got on a scale until my fifth
fight uh we wrapped our own hands if you
were gonna wrap your hands you brought
your own gloves you agreed on the rules
at the at the fighter meeting so some
fights wouldn't have the same rules like
two guys well I don't want to do this
and then another one it was just Honor
Code the referee couldn't remember what
it was I mean I only bring to you when I
stayed in the sport in my first fight in
1999 when I stayed in the sport the
commissions were formed in 2001 2002 the
sport is in a lot better place but I
didn't know anything about that I didn't
know anything about fighting guys your
size or fighting guy you know and
agreeing on on it was it was anybody it
was any anyone at any time and and I
kept that color and I was proud of that
code and I know that I uh I broke some
eggs on my way to to making some
omelettes but I stepped in there every
time I agreed to I never pulled out and
if I had to answer for something I
answered for it the hard way well your
resume proves that that is definitely
the case Trail you're for who's who when
I look through your record it it is not
it's not good there isn't You could
argue you've got as good a resume as
anyone in fighting so you know be proud
of that man and uh honestly it's truly
an honor to have you on the show I've
looked up to you for years and uh thanks
for entertaining us and keep up the
great work man by the way I didn't
followed you I watch you start this
thing with a microphone and an idea now
you got over a million you're one of the
biggest shows out there truly uh great
job you did it the hard way you build up
a reputation for yourself you got people
that trust you they come to you I'm
proud of you man that means I love
Trails thanks so much and if you ever
need anything uh well if you're ever in
London then you got my number bro all
right take it easy man